here's Savannah Hernandez I've had her
on the show I believe one or two times
who's she often goes out to colleges and
she tries to Red Pill uh you know these
leftist college students in real time
she was on Tim Poole's podcast last
night and I think she made a really good
point about how to get wins and that
dare I say it but the right
conservatives whatever you want to call
them are actually doing the right thing
but it's not just because of Tucker and
Tim it's because of you
20 of people no longer buy beer then Bud
light's market cap will drop by 20 and
stay there and once it stabilizes 20
lower it they will say the the boy cuts
over the decline in sales has ended
despite the fact what really happened is
no one is coming back to buy their beer
yeah right right and you know what I
will say too I actually am proud proud
of the right wing for you know staking
it Anheuser Bush and actually sending
this message because typically in the
past I feel like we get angry about
things but we're internet Warriors and
that's about it so I mean seeing the
pushback on this uh has been great and
uh I think it has sent a message to a
lot of other corporations as well and
they're going to start being more
careful about uh what they're
advertising
okay so I think you see the connection
I'm trying to make here we don't know
whether Tucker voluntarily left or they
pushed him out the door there was a
little bit of both but there's a
game-changing moment happening in
television media and and let's say
online media then if you connect that
with the fact that a game-changing
moment happened just last week with this
massive boycott people are not going to
go back to Bud Light like you can feel
it Savannah's right this is different
than usually people just tweet about
things and I'm so angry about something
and I threw my Keurig coffee machine in
the garbage
something is different right now and
these these wins these little moments
they start sticking together and then
then something can start taking form so
this is the result of you the non-wo
consumer the decision maker the person
with a little autonomy over your life
and your dollars uh saying to the market
hey I would not like to be abused
relentlessly anymore and then you know
what happens after that then the market
does some different things so we've got
some info here from the daily wire
Bud Light marketing VP takes leave of
absence amid Dylan Mulvaney controversy
that was the woman who uh set up the
whole thing in the first place who we
played the video of her last week you
remember who was basically saying we
don't like the Frat Boys that are
drinking Bud Light so we want it to be
more diverse and here we go well she's
now okay she's out a little more from
the daily wire Anheuser-Busch places
another top marketing executive on leave
after Bud Light transgender
controversy so now do you see it guys
that didn't happen solely because Tucker
talked about it or because bongino
talked about it or any of us talked
about it even though we did it was
because people heard the message they
were fed up enough and then they walked
into the supermarket and they said today
I will have Connor beer please
Coors Light instead of Bud Light you can
probably do better than Coors Light
people but people made choices
[Music]